hi rooster Brothers here we are the
directors of Avengers infinity war and
we're here to talk about every hero in
avenge isn't any war so let's get
started
Tony Stark is Iron Man get a lot of ways
he is the heart and soul of the Marvel
Universe
Tony Stark's powers are fascinating
because they basically come from his
mind they come from the scientific
knowledge his brilliance his
intelligence and his sort of aspirations
it allows you to sort of track a journey
in the character and watch him evolve
and it's sort of better himself through
the use of these powers he's a
fascinating character it's character we
love because he's imminently flawed and
we like characters that are challenging
and that expressed their humanity and I
think Tony Stark does that as well as
any of the characters he started off as
a narcissistic alcoholic and grew into a
hero which I think makes him eminently
relatable and why he signifies what the
Marvel Universe stands for is in his
notion of a character first and that
heroes are defined through choices that
they make he's one of the most exciting
power sets of any of the characters Thor
is an Asgardian God he started off heir
to the throne of Asgard and found
himself not worthy of taking the mantle
of king of the Asgardians I think he's
been on a very complicated journey where
he struggles with his ability to feel
worthy and be worthy well he's never
before me yeah he has
he's never fought me twice he's looking
for a moral compass in his life what we
love about him and infinity war is that
he has been torn down to his essential
parts and he goes on on a hero's journey
which a very underdog journey for
someone of his stature because he has
lost everything in his
in a lot of ways he is the driving
hero's arc of the movie which stands in
direct opposition to Thanos's argument I
would argue that head for chopped his
head off at the end of the movie that
the movie will belong to Thor but
because he didn't it belongs to Thanos
now that these actors have played these
characters over multiple movies Chris
Hemsworth was very valuable coming off
Ragnarok because we were executing these
movies before we were able to fully
process what had been done with the
character both Chris Hemsworth and Taika
Waititi were really really important to
us in terms of understanding that very
unique journey that that character had
in that movie so that we can figure out
how to pick up the narrative with where
he was in his life now the home is in a
very interesting place in infinity war
he in banner I have been at odds over
who controls the host body since we
first met Bruce Banner
it's a Jekyll and Hyde relationship they
grow at turns weary with one another
refuses to help banner because he
believes that banner only uses the Hulk
to solve problems and Hulk I think it's
starting to perceive himself as who
should control the homes body because he
doesn't feel like banner
brings an awful lot to the table in
infinity war banner has to become the
hero and go to war with fans of minions
and he does so any successful
but ultimately I'm not beating fan OHS
Captain America I'm Steve Rogers we
entered the MCU by directing Captain
America Winter Soldier what we love
about the character is the humility of
the character the fact that he came from
very basic roots and through sort of his
will and his aspiration and the sort of
fortune of being chosen for the Super
Soldier program he was able to sort of
make more of himself than he would have
been able to otherwise I think that's
what people really admire about the
character Joe and I never really
responded to the earlier comics where he
is sort of a simplistic symbol of
patriotism we were always interested in
exploring something a little more
complex with the character and really
understanding him on more of a human
level that's I think the journey that
we've been on with that character
through several films now Black Widow
her unique distinction of being a
villain who's turned into a hero makes
her for us one of the richer characters
to work with scarlet trances incredible
range is an actress but can embody at
the same time vulnerability and
toughness and I think that's very
difficult to do we've been fortunate
enough to grow that character over three
films Winter Soldier it's a war an
infinity war and Winter Soldier we found
so compelling about pairing her up with
Captain America was that he is a service
paragon of morality and she is a paragon
of gray but they've they've grown
together and I think when you find them
in this movie and they've been The
Secret Avengers for two years because
they're being hunted by Ross and the
government they're like a tight-knit
family now her Samuelsson and Steve
Rogers it's hardened all of them in a
way you can't go on the run without it
affecting you emotionally so I think all
of those characters specifically the
ones who survived infinity war cap and
Natasha you will see them with a much
much harder edge all right back up Sam
you win war machine Rhodey is coming out
of Civil War and we lost the use of his
legs
he's a military man who understands duty
and sacrifice the moment where he
accepts cap and widow and Sam when they
return is a real testament to his
character
and who he is he understands that the
priority of saving the universe
outweighs the priority of petty
differences you know he's a very noble
character and he's been becoming an
integral part of the Avengers team dr.
strange we were really thrilled to be
able to work with dr. strange for the
first time in Avengers infinity war and
one of the things we were most excited
about with that character in this film
is sort of smashing him against the
character of Tony Stark I will not
hesitate to let either of you die we
like the fact that the two characters
are kind of narcissistic and I have an
alpha energy to them and we thought well
what happens when you put them in the
same room together one dedicated to this
idea of science and one dedicated to
this idea of conflict that would result
from their different points of views so
Doctor Strange played a very powerful
role in Avengers infinity war as a kid
is a comic book collector what I loved
about dr. strange was there was a
mystical element to certainly not I
speak for myself Jaime more than
everyone else because of his connection
to magic dr. strange is a prescient
character and the fact that he was able
to view the events unfolding at 14
million times and watching them lose 40
million times is weighing heavy on his
heart and doesn't save him at the end of
the movie so again we wanted to show
that no matter what level of power you
had Thanos is an unstoppable force and
ultimately the victory was going to be
is spider-man it was a great thrill for
us to be able to reintroduce this
character with Tom Holland playing
spider-man and and the relationship the
special relationship that he has been
trying to start kid
Devendra that mentor-mentee relationship
is very rich and complex and having cast
the character as a real teen we really
set up a very similar dynamic between
Robert Downey jr. and Tom Holland
that's very reflective of the characters
Robert was very much a mentor to Tom
through the shooting process and it's
not easy to play a superhero and I think
Robert was very instrumental in helping
Tom find that voice in him for that
character it was very charming how it
was so reflective of the character
relationship that dancer has tremendous
potential as a character in the Marvel
Universe and I think what Conda is
essential to whatever may happen post
Avengers infinity war to how the world
may deal with what has happened to them
Chadwicks portrayal of that character
adds a whole new level to the Marvel
Universe he's bringing a quiet intensity
and a reality to that character the
technology that what Conda has at its
disposal is invaluable to repairing the
world and moving forward he was a
character that we loved working with and
civil war you see by the end of the film
is that you know he rises above the fray
and he displays forgiveness that
nobility is critical and again something
that separates him from some of the
other characters in Robin universe
because that is not always the case
that's what makes them all unique
mores an extremely strong character she
is a daughter of Thanos which means she
was held captive by Thanos as Thanos was
moving through the universe conquering
worlds he would collect a range of
children she also was very special one
for him he had a relationship with her
unlike any he had with any of his other
children he thought more highly of her
than he thought of any of his other
children and it's sort of her struggle
to find her own identity and realize how
to push back against Thanos is a big
part of her journey that journey is
shared with her sister nebula like
Gamora and nebula is a child of Thanos
not a literal child but she has also
been collected by him and while nebula
also finds a way to finally liberate
herself from and oppose her father she
comes to that part of her journey a
little more slowly than Gamora does and
there remains a lot of tension between
the two characters revolving around the
the two arcs that they have to go
through in the end they end up both
standing against Thanos and standing
together with one another I Loki Prince
of Asgard Loki god of mischief he is
Thor his brother is another character
who began his journey as a villain and I
think finally shows his true colors an
infinity war when he makes an attempt to
murder Tanis to save his own brother to
tragic consequences we need to destroy
this vision of course plays a very
special role in infinity war he is the
only character who has a infinity stone
actually built into his body
we knew that put him in a very special
place in our storytelling because of
that his sort of well being and safety
was at
if Thanos was going after the stone so
his relationship with Wanda was very
important to us in this film because as
their romantic relationship continues to
develop the stakes of that character and
his life become so important to her stay
one of the most tragic moments of the
movie in one of our favorite moments of
the movie of course is when she has to
take his life in order to stop vanos
from getting the stone and by destroying
the stone that's in his head and to
watch those two characters approach that
moment in the way that they did really
one of the most inspiring parts of the
story for us Paul Bettany has always
said he thinks about vision as his
primary motivation is just someone who's
seeking to understand humanity and I
think that when that final gesture
vision really achieved a full humanity
got rich like Black Widow had a
complicated history if you start off as
a villain it's usually a you know you're
motivated by self-interest what's so
compelling about her is that she has
become one of the most characters that
are readily display empathy and love
towards someone else her love story with
vision was really the essential core of
the film and the real tragedy of
infinity war was as they were cementing
their relationship with one another this
external force injected itself you know
forced her to make an incredibly
difficult decision as a hero could you
kill someone you love in order to save
the universe
it was doubly tragic too because of her
history or character history of having
lost her brother certainly one of the
more tragic and also in some ways you
know inspiring parts of the story for us
Sam Wilson Falcon Allegro d & Chawla
understands how to put the common good
ahead of any self-interest he was a
military hero came out of a secret
program of the Falcon project his
superpowers quote-unquote come from his
his heart and a soul that makes him
distinctive Winter Soldier the journey
that Bucky Barnes has gone on from being
caps best friend being captured by Hydra
and then sort of experimented on by
Hydra and turned into the Winter Soldier
that was the heart of the conflict of
Captain America Winter Soldier for Joe
and I was the idea that cap was in a
situation where he had to fight his best
friend and the sort of dedication to
reaching that friend that he still
believed was inside the Winter Soldier
was sort of the heart of the film for us
we get away with a lot of darkness and
that character because of the fact that
he is mind controlled even more so than
other characters who have sort of
villainous pasts like Scarlet Witch or
Black Widow this character we can push
that that villainy even further that's
part of what makes the character both
dangerous and fun others
[Music]
Heimdall was the all-seeing all-knowing
gatekeeper for Asgard at the beginning
of infinity war sacrifices his life to
send the Hulk to earth so that Bruce
Banner can warn everyone there about the
threat of Thanos
Ocoee is the head of the Dermalogica
tasked with protecting the king of
Wakanda black panther and she takes her
job very very seriously and it comes to
the ultimate test in Avengers infinity
war he trees the dwarf is part of a very
special race of beings who are weapons
makers and they have served the
Asgardian kings for for many millennia
Kings weapon he has skills and tools
that create weapons that are like Thor's
hammer like his axe in this film that
magical can make yeah yeah they can view
them with the power of the Bifrost so
you know his skill set is is revered at
banks and 6 elemental crystals Wang is
great magician who complements Doctor
Strange as a detector of the sanctorum
and the mystic arts even strange have a
competitive and combative relationship I
think that that's what makes them
special is that they are better as a
team than they are individually kick
names take casts mantis one of the most
fun members of the guardians of the
galaxy
she's a newer member she has very
special skills that can reach people on
emotional levels and and mentally she
plays a very pivotal role in our
Avengers plan to take down Thanos and
the climax of the film things go ride
nonetheless but she she certainly was
source a great fun I've mastered the
ability
I was standing so incredibly still that
I'd become invisible to the eye Drax the
destroyer he's born of tragic
circumstances his family was murdered by
Thanos as minions part of Thanos his
calling of the universe prior to
obtaining the stones
Thanos would go planet by planet destroy
half the population of each planet
indiscriminately he's a character
seeking revenge for his family but his
oddity creates a really interesting
tonal character those at times tragic
and at other times hilarious Groot
because of most people's inability to
understand him I think he's very
spiritual character and also cause he's
elemental you know he's a tree he's a
very powerful character his heart as
well is something that carries him as a
hero
it was illustrated in the first
guardians when you made that sacrifice
and in this film even though he's
regressed in his going through his
adolescence again which is a tendency to
make you a little self-interested in a
little internal he does at the moment
when he's needed make the right choice
and offers up his own to complete the
weapon that can bring about the the end
of Thanos
how much for the god not to sell okay
how much video rocket is a favorite of
many people oh I'll get that out and he
keeps himself very distanced on an
emotional level from other characters
and that makes him very tough to crack
and very tough to even get along with
sometimes but that's part of the fun of
the character is figuring out ways where
he can emotionally connect with someone
and that was a favorite storyline of
ours in this film an infinity war with
that special relationship that he
develops with Thor seeing Thor suffer
like he's come to suffer
fact that he's lost everything and
everyone finally kind of cracks rocket I
think there's also a little bit of self
interest in there he knows that
authorities and sort of get focused and
and and do the job he's supposed to do
they may all die at the hands of Thanos
nonetheless they do the form of a very
special relationship in this movie
star-lord begin a new character he grew
up under extreme circumstances captured
by space pirates raised by pirates taken
away from his mother was dying of cancer
at a very early age I think it's made
him a bit of a rogue I like your plan
except it sucks so let me do the plan
and that way it might be really good
star-lord is someone that we relate to
greatly his superpowers are his wits his
passion and its strengths the character
again he's not somebody's been endowed
with superpowers outside of his heritage
with his father but this idea that you
know he relates more to his humanity
than he does to this godlike part of
himself is what makes him so interesting
to us sherry is the smartest person in
our universe she is the sister of
T'Challa a princess of Wakanda and she
is the brains behind you know wakanda's
incredibly advanced technology ayo is a
key member of the dawn elijah I would
say oklet's right-hand she is charged
with protecting Shuri in the lab to keep
her safe while she tries to remove the
stone from vision and she had a very
memorable but brief showdown with Black
Widow and Captain America Civil War move
well you will be moved
Nick Fury makes a very brief and
unfortunately appearance and there's
infinity war but none of the Avengers
are here without Nick Fury he is the
lifeblood of the Avengers program and
and the reason that the world even had
the Avengers in the first place
Maria hill is a SHIELD agent
she's worked very closely with Nick Fury
also has a brief but unfortunate
appearance in infinity or with Nick Fury
I'm like I can't believe how many
characters know where the Russo brothers
thanks wired fans for watching we hope
you learned a lot Thanks
[Music]
together we can stop the house